por fin logré darle de comer a mi gato
así que creo que es un muy buen momento
para aprender acerca del coeficiente de
precios por ganancias el coeficiente de
precio por ganancia
ganancia ahora muchas veces vas a ver
que la gente se refiere a esto
simplemente como el coeficiente p
esto es por sus siglas en inglés price
to earn ings es una forma más rápida de
decirlo simplemente es el coeficiente p
entonces vamos a pensar en el
coeficiente p de la compañía que
estábamos estudiando que era una
compañía de artesanías va entonces
supongamos que el valor del mercado sea
ya dijimos antes que el valor en libro
por acción de esta compañía era de 5
pesos porque el valor en libro de su
capital era de 5 millones había un
millón de acciones y cuando dividíamos 5
millones entre un millón nos quedaba 5
pesos ahora vamos a darle un precio en
la bolsa de valores o sea no sé
supongamos que se llama la compañía de
artesanías y su símbolo en la bolsa
mexicana de valores escobar cover
compañía de artesanías y supongamos que
su precio su precio ahorita se está
comprando y vendiendo digamos en déjame
pensar en un buen número digamos que se
está cotizando en tres pesos con 50
centavos
en tres pesos con cincuenta centavos muy
bien ahora aprendimos en el primer vídeo
que el precio por sí mismo no nos dice
mucho entonces vamos a poner cuántas
acciones hay ya sabemos que hay un
millón entonces hay un millón de
acciones de modo que la capitalización
de mercado o sea lo que el mercado
piensa que es el valor del capital de
esta compañía es la multiplicación de
estos dos números si hay un millón de
acciones y cada una vale 350 entonces el
mercado piensa que el capital de la
compañía vale 3.5 millones de pesos
verdad entonces lo escribo por aquí es
3.5 millones de pesos muy bien ahora
estoy aquí es el valor en mercado de
capital es lo que el mercado piensa que
el capital vale entonces eso esta
interesante mira en nuestro caso el
valor en libros del capital es de 5
millones de pesos pero el mercado dice
no no no o sea la verdad no le creo
mucho a estos contadores a lo mejor se
están inventando algunas cosas entonces
voy a decir que simplemente vale
es punto 5 millones de pesos ok en este
caso lo que sucede es que la compañía se
está vendiendo más barato con respecto
al valor en libros y ahorita no voy a
meter en muchos detalles pero esto en
realidad es algo raro ve esto no pasa a
menos que la gente sospecha mucho de la
contabilidad pues de la empresa o de los
registros o a menos que piensen que pues
este activo de acá ya no vale tanto es
un activo digamos que se depreció va o
sea que su vida útil ya disminuyó por
ejemplo si tienes un montón de vídeos en
viaje o en dvd y así de un día para otro
no se sale una compañía que reta
películas por internet entonces pues a
lo mejor pues sus películas ya no valen
tanto verdad pero bueno vamos a hablar
más de eso acerca bueno de acerca de eso
cuando veamos algunos ejemplos reales en
este caso nuestra capitalización de
mercado está por debajo del valor en
libro eso se ve desde el precio verdad
sea fíjate si pensamos en cosas por
acción el valor en libro es de 5 pesos
pero el precio por acción según el
mercado es de 3 pesos con 50 centavos
entonces se puede ver desde el precio
se puede ver que hay un descuento verdad
ahora cuánto fueron las ganancias de la
compañía según recuerdo eran de 35
centavos por acción a ver déjame
escribirlo ganancias las ganancias
totales de 2008 eran de 350 mil pesos
350 mil pesos en 2008 verdad ahora
supongamos que estamos viendo esto desde
la perspectiva de que ya se terminó el
2008 pongamos que estamos al principio
de 2009 no sé digamos el primero de
enero de 2009 y que la compañía ya sacó
su informe de ganancias aunque
usualmente toma más que usualmente toma
de 45 a 90 días pero bueno supongamos
que ya sacaron su informe de ganancias
entonces es como a esta compañía hizo
350 mil pesos en 2008 otra forma de
decirlo que a lo mejor lo puedas ver
cuando veas cosas en inglés es que a
esto le llaman el dtm el tms ellington
mont en inglés o sea las ganancias de
los últimos 12 meses y la aclaración
vale la pena para saber si con ganancias
se refieren a las de este año o las
futuras o para saber a cuáles pues aquí
en este caso particular son las
ganancias de tm o sea
pasado vamos ahora a gpa gp a ganancias
por acción entonces las ganancias por
acciones este número entre la cantidad
de acciones que es 35 centavos ok
entonces simplemente para aprender qué
es el precio por ganancias vamos a
calcularlo después vamos a hablar un
poquito de qué se trata qué significa y
tal vez podamos tener una discusión de
qué quiere decir que una compañía tenga
un precio por ganancias alto o bajo y de
hecho se puede poner un poco complicado
pero en este caso literalmente se trata
de tomar el precio de dividirlo entre el
gpa entonces déjame cambiar el color es
nada más para hacer las cosas un poco
más entretenidas entonces el coeficiente
pp es igual al precio por acción
entonces sería igual a 3.50 tres pesos
con 50 centavos dividido entre el gpa
entre 35 centavos las ganancias por
acción en este caso nos queda un
coeficiente de 10 muy bien que dice esto
de aquí bueno hay algunas formas en las
cuales se puede pensar en esto una de
éstas es invertir el coeficiente de digo
casi nadie habla del coeficiente de
ganancias por precio pero según yo sí es
buena idea porque se conecta mucho con
otro
conceptos financieros entonces para
aclarar esto no es estándar es más o
menos raro pero creo que es una buena
idea para pensar las cosas entonces está
la aclaración el coeficiente de precios
por ganancia sería el inverso de esto o
sea 35 centavos entre 350 que sería
igual a un décimo o bien 10% muy bien
entonces la forma en la cual podemos
pensar en esto es que si estás pagando
350 pesos por acción por esta compañía y
supongamos que la compañía el siguiente
año bueno estoy acá es el ptm verdad lo
que ganó el año pasado pero supongamos
que esta compañía es muy estable y que
hace lo mismo cada año no está creciendo
no está disminuyendo -se supongamos que
estoy acá no sólo es el ptm sino que
también es déjame introducir un poco de
terminología acá arriba este tm pero
también podemos tener ganancias forward
ganancias forward que son las ganancias
forward a lo mejor puedes adivinar y
aquí arriba es lo que le pasó a la
compañía verdad en el año pasado o bien
en los 12 meses pasados pues por otro
lado para las ganancias forward hay un
montón de cuates con maestrías en la
administración
estás trabajando para los bancos hacen
un montón de informes estudian la
industria se juntan con la compañía vaya
son expertos analistas y ellos en
conjunto llegan a un numerito dicen
sabes que nosotros creemos que esta
compañía va a hacer que esta compañía no
va a cambiar sus ingresos es súper
estable y por tanto creemos que van a
hacer 35 centavos de ganancia en 2009
también también entonces en este caso
esto de aquí serían las ganancias
forward usualmente si es una compañía
pues bien formada va a haber 10 15 ó 20
analistas van a promediar todos sus
pronósticos personales y si este número
es digamos en este caso 35 centavos
entonces a esto le llaman el consenso
entonces el consenso simplemente lo que
piensan los analistas de la parte
vendedora que se va a ganar si no dicho
que en la parte vendedora a lo mejor
debería hacer algunos vídeos pero como
ya dije la palabra déjame explicar un
poco la parte vendedora son por ejemplo
los bancos de inversión y la razón por
la cual son la parte vendedora es vaya
sorpresa porque siempre están vendiendo
cosas están vendiendo acciones están
haciendo transacciones y escriben estos
reportes
e investigación porque quieren ir con
algunos inversionistas institucionales o
gente con mucho dinero y básicamente
venderles acciones van con ellos con los
bancos y los inversionistas y les dicen
mira te conviene comprar compañía de
artesanías porque su coeficiente pe es
de 10 eso está mucho mejor que deuda
gubernamental porque estarías ganando
10% y aquí es justo donde se conectan
los conceptos y el precio por ganancia
es de 10 y se mantiene constante esto
quiere decir que la compañía tiene un
crecimiento anual de 10% lo cual es
mejor que pagarés federales eso es lo
que es la parte vendedor ahora al lado
comprador el lado vendedor es el que
publica estos reportes un analista del
lado comprador es alguien que trabaja
para un fondo de cobertura o un fondo de
pensiones o no se incluso para un
capitalista de riesgo y lo que hace es
administrar el dinero de otras personas
básicamente su trabajo consiste en ver
si este numerito que sacaron los otros
analistas pues si concuerda con la
realidad y para esto hacen sus propios
análisis el lado de compra son las
personas que administran el dinero y
tienen que decidir dónde invertir el
lado de ventas son las personas que
hacen análisis para decir que mi acción
es buena y que sería bueno comprar
bueno esto de ahí simplemente fue un
pequeño paréntesis pero regresando aquí
entonces el precio por ganancias vimos
que es 10 pero la razón por la cual
quería hacer ganancias por precio es que
nos conecta cosas como rendimiento e
interés sabes o sea déjame hacer una
analogía con una cuenta bancaria
supongamos que en mi cuenta bancaria
tengo no sé digamos 100 pesos déjame
ponerlo por aquí es otro paréntesis
entonces cuenta bancaria cuenta bancaria
supongamos que tengo 100 pesos en mi
cuenta bancaria y que por un año me dan
un interés de 2% supongamos que está
garantizado porque es un certificado de
depósito que me da 102 pesos al final
del año entonces este 2% fueron mis
ganancias
tuve dos pesos en ganancias verdad
ganancias entonces la forma en la cual
podemos pensar en una cuenta de banco es
bueno cuando pagamos por esa cuenta de
banco pues pague 100 pesos verdad pague
en un sentido de que lo deposite
entonces el precio sería de 100 pesos y
lo que gane
dos pesos entonces tiene un peso de 50
bs 50 o si haces un ep o sea un
ganancias por precio entonces tendríamos
dos pesos divididos en 300 que es igual
a 2% que normalmente así es como
pensamos en los bancos verdad estamos
pensando en el interés que es 2% ahora
esto de aquí nos lleva a una pregunta
interesante si un banco
simplemente me da 2% por mi dinero y
esta compañía pues más o menos
creyéndole al consenso me está dando 10%
por qué rayos abriría una cuenta de
banco verdad porque me metería todo mi
dinero aquí porque estoy pagando un
precio por ganancias más alto por una
cuenta bancaria que lo que estoy
dispuesto a hacer por esta compañía
porque allá más o menos agarraste la
onda de que mientras menor sea el precio
por ganancia mientras todo lo demás de
igual verdad eso es importante mientras
menor sea el precio por ganancia estás
pagando menos por algo te gustaría tener
un menor precio por ganancia por el
mismo activo porque entonces estás
ganando lo mismo por un precio más
barato
o sea cuando bajas de precio por
ganancias estás aumentando el ganancias
por precio entonces estás aumentando el
rendimiento y entonces te gustaría
maximizar el rendimiento déjame acabar
este vídeo con una pregunta básica
porque alguien dejaría su dinero en el
banco con un derecho del 2% o un precio
por ganancias de 50 cuando en realidad
podría tener un precio por ganancias de
10 con compañía de artesanías y la
respuesta es por qué estoy acá arriba es
muy incierto o sea no sabemos qué le va
a pasar a la compañía de artesanías a lo
mejor esto de aquí es un gran esquema de
ponzi y digo hay muy muy pocas compañías
que lo son esta es otra cosa de la cual
hay que hablar riesgo verdad porque si
sospechas un poquito en estas compañías
a lo mejor no te convenga comprar de
aquí en eeuu hay muy buenos contadores
hay muchos muy buenos estándares de
contabilidad entonces a lo mejor no es
tan malo comprar allá pero hay otros
países en los cuales no tienen tan
buenos estándares entonces a lo mejor no
puedes invertir ahí tan tranquilamente
otra razón puede ser la siguiente puedes
decir bueno los analistas me dijeron que
la compañía va a tener una ganancia de
35 centavos el próximo
pero la verdad no les creo nada tú
puedes tener razones para creer que hay
mucho riesgo en compañías de artesanías
que hay mucha volatilidad no sé porqué
puede salir del negocio o puede tener un
fuerte competidor chino y entonces crees
que no vale la pena pero una razón más
incluso aunque pienses que compañía de
artesanías va a seguir ganando 35
centavos por acción por toda la vida una
razón por la cual preferirías tener una
cuenta bancaria en vez de tener acciones
de ccoo ar es porque en el banco tu
depósito está totalmente garantizado que
garantizan tus 102 pesos porque esos los
depósitos te con un certificado de
depósito digamos de un año y entonces
segurito dentro de un año te van a
devolver tu dinero y más aún si está
asegurado por el ipab pero en este caso
aunque el precio por ganancias sea el
mismo algo horrible puede suceder con el
mercado puede ser que todo el mundo
empiece a perder credibilidad y que haya
signos en una devaluación muy grande
las personas se espantan baja el precio
muy abajo de 350 puede ser muy volátil y
no se osea de un día para otro el precio
podría bajar a digamos a un peso con 75
centavos entonces pues podría ser ahora
una buena oferta verdad pero si tú
tenías fíjate aquí tenemos un precio por
ganancia de 5 verdad iría a la mitad
pero si tienes acciones no te conviene
nada baja muchísimo entonces de repente
si tienes acciones tu dinero básicamente
se va a ir a la mitad entonces hay
volatilidad en el precio aunque suponga
que las ganancias son estables ahora
pues más o menos para agarrar el
saborcito porque alguien realísticamente
pagaría un precio por ganancias más alto
pues simplemente la razón es por
seguridad entonces estoy aquí está
garantizado 1 y 2 tiene liquidez tienes
liquidez porque en cualquier momento
puedes ir por tu dinero verdad puedes
retirar del cajero y sabes que vas a
poder sacar tus 100 pesos
aquí no hay volatilidad pero acá arriba
pues ya sabes hay volatilidad no sabes
qué va a pasar con el mercado a lo mejor
sea loca y el precio se va a la mitad
y esa otra cosa lo de la liquidez acá
arriba puede ser que tengas problemas de
liquidez porque la compañía chiquita y
sea difícil vender sus acciones y a lo
mejor no encuentras a nadie que te
compre las acciones no son líquidas un
ejemplo exagerado de falta de liquidez
es que tengas una casa de 20 millones de
pesos pero que no la puedas cambiar por
efectivo porque en realidad no hay nadie
o muy pocas personas que te la puedan
pagar salir vamos a dejarle aquí en el
siguiente vídeo vamos a platicar un poco
más acerca de precio por ganancias vamos
a hablar acerca de crecimiento de
estabilidad y de otras cosas